nobody listens HR hi Megan I thought
that I have been clear about the number
of buttons with champion buttons on a
shirt you're serious about that it's
winter
can we put dancer and prancer back in
their stable
are you body shaming her right now some
people here might find your outfit
offensive well some people might find
your outfit offensive and really
confusing oh I thought was clear this is
a multi-denominational holiday sweater
it has christmas hanukkah kwanzaa the
Buddhist day of enlightenment and Boxing
Day on it everyone's included is
everyone included what about what about
the the Mormons what about the Jews for
Jesus
what about Scientologists yeah nikka
season what about Shintoism Satanism
right what about something for the
Satanist Jeremy come on III admire the
standing you're taking but let's
schedule the protest rally for after the
work day shall we and and and Mary it
was photo time
thank you good morning everybody you
can't silence us all I know why you took
a medical leave